[Musique]
depuis l'enfance je suis fasciné par les
langues j'en ai inventé une
tu as inventé tout une langue oui j'ai
créé des histoires des légendes
[Musique]
raconte moi une histoire dans la langue
de son choix
c'est une histoire qui parle de voyage
deux voyages pour se mettre à l'épreuve
aventure on devrait former un club une
confrérie
nous changeons le monde
grâce au pouvoir de l'art la musique la
poésie et toi attaque m je veux écrire
d'une magie qui dépasse tout ce qu'on a
pu ressentir jusqu'à présent
parce que signifie aimer
et être aimé
c'est la guerre loriot terre est en
guerre
et
les ans avec laquelle vous saisissez
leur rythme de la langue je dois le
reconnaître monsieur tolkien
je n'ai jamais rien vu de semblable
c'est plus qu'une simple amitié
c'est une alliance
invincible
une communauté